[Musique]
l'agglomération de dunkerque et les
alpes-maritimes se re confine à compter
de cette fin de semaine décidée par
olivier ferrand
la mesure a pour but d'endiguer
l'incidence alarmante à laquelle la
ville du nord est le département du sud
font face ce confinement prend effet à
partir de 18 heures jusqu'à lundi 6h du
matin dunkerquois et niçois auront
besoin d'un motif valable et d'une
attestation pour sortir on voulait
donner la chance à la prévention mais la
situation générale est plus difficile la
population doit le comprendre
l'hôpital est saturé le personnel
soignant épuisé maintenant j'attends que
les dunkerquois respecte les décisions
le préfet de dunkerque a enfin tranché
sur la durée de la mesure qui sera égal
au confinement décidé à nice pour les
deux prochains week-ends derrière le
président des patriotes florian
philippot plus de 200 personnes ont
manifesté vendredi à nice contre ces
mesures
j'ai voulu venir à nice qui est
l'épicentre de cette tyrannie sanitaires
ici on re qu'on file alors que l'on sait
que ça ne fonctionne pas il faut ouvrir
la france en france les départements les
plus touchés sont les alpes-maritimes le
pas de calais les bouches-du-rhône la
moselle et le var en métropole ainsi que
mayotte et saint barthélemy en outre-mer
face à cette situation la mairie de
paris propose d'instaurer un confinement
de week-end pour une durée de trois
semaines qui selon anne hidalgo pourrait
ensuite permettre un déconfinement
progressif des affirmations rapidement
battu en brèche par le gouvernement en
déplacement au centre hospitalier de
nantes en loire atlantique jean castex a
tenu à répondre à la merde paris vous
avez entendu la mairie de paris dira
qu'il faut qu on confine trois semaines
et puis c'est fini
mais vous savez très bien qu'avec les
variants et cetera ce n'est pas possible
il ne faut jamais raconter des fadaises
aucune nouvelle mesure à l'ordre du jour
donc mais face à la remontée de
l'épidémie sur le territoire vingt
départements sont désormais placés sous
surveillance renforcée dont toute
l'ile-de-france
ces zones territoriales pourraient faire
l'objet de mesures de confinement locaux
à partir du week-end 6 mars
si la situation ne s'améliore pas en
france on dénombre plus de 85 mille
décès liés aux cours aux navires us et
près de quatre millions de personnes
contaminées